hi slugs i am coming on the road this
fall as you know i'm coming to florida
and those tour dates i'm coming to
orlando dania beach and tampa but new
dates i'm coming to portland at the
helium comedy club november 3rd and
november 4th i'm coming to san francisco
at cobb's comedy club and you can get
tickets wherever you find them online
just google and sleepover by esther.com
for a new drop for my merch my clothing
line goodbye all right hey trash slugs
um i have been having the greatest time
of my freaking life entertaining you
guys and having fun with you guys on the
road please come to tempe arizona at the
improv august 6 through 8. i will be at
caroline's on broadway in new york city
coming back home august 12th through
14th i'm going to be in hartford
connecticut at the funny bone august
27th to 28th i'll be at hilarity's
hilarities in cleveland ohio september
9th through 11th
good nights riley september 23rd to 25th
and a lot more just look it up on my
website annieletterman.com
who is this [ __ ] like i know i kalila
introduced me to your friend because i'm
hearing these things and i'm like i'm
confused i'm excited i'm turned on
here's what it says
here's what i'll tell you about geo when
i first met her i thought she was a twin
flame number one we both had forearm
tattoos
i feel as though she has the same very
warm
like
conf like when you're around her you
just all immediately feel comfortable
should i leave the room i feel weird and
then we were like geo if we were to
swing the other way it would be each
with each other are you serious yeah
absolutely we made a lesbian pack
absolutely i've never kissed a girl but
i'm going to kiss her yeah
at one point are in it to win it yeah
if bart and bobby leave us
yeah first number we call i don't even
think they have to leave us
[Music]
how did you guys meet
um we met through bobby yeah you guys
met bobby first yeah you guys were
friends with him yeah and then bobby
introduced me to the pack yeah and i
fell in love with her instantly i did
too when i met her how did you meet her
uh i met her in the green room at one of
bobby shows and and i i guess i showed
her my boobs immediately and then i was
like which one was it what boob
it matters oh yeah the way she does it
though is that she really asks for
feedback she's like do you like them
it's never just can i show you my boobs
like what are your thoughts that's so
weird did you get them done is that why
no i didn't i'm i
they're just epic they're not epic lila
what color are nibbles
i don't know
i really like change chameleons
they're just depending on your mood
they're sleeping right now so i can't
it's hard to get a good read okay you
know when they're asleep versus awake
mood rings yeah i know what i'm talking
about i only show my breasts
if they're awake
what does awake mean
my nipples are hard you know what it
means oh and they're hard yeah yes i
will never i dare not show they're not
they're asleep are your boobs real no
they're okay that makes me feel they're
really great thank you i had a baby and
they got more natural looking oh yeah
because they were harder and i really
wanted those fake pamela anderson
titties where like people know that
their face yeah like i wanted this line
to show and i was like cool they're fake
that's what i was going for and then i
had a baby i breastfed and then they
went wow but i feel like that's the good
look yeah that's they look good they
look but i wanted them fake really
that's a look you were going for a
little bit i mean they're not really big
yeah but i i like the perky like
unrealistic look
i i like both looks i'll say that i but
i do sometimes i'll admit to you guys i
do think about
if you know i ever have kids and things
you know because things can get really
messy in there like maybe that would be
a time
that i would get something done
potentially i don't know when i was
little i always thought i was going to
get fake boobs like i prayed for boobs
like i i just that was like my dream and
you got them well
those are great boobs my boobs didn't
look that big you guys yeah i was going
to say gio was the first person who
reassured me that even after pregnancy
you still can't have a gorilla grip
[ __ ] oh yeah
wait what yeah
but she doesn't very nicely we well she
does not know how to do kegel exercises
so we've been trying to teach her over
the last couple of episodes so i feel
like that's the key to maintaining a
gorilla grip what was the description
that you gave her
i just like work on that muscle well we
gave her an exerciser we actually gave
her this um instrument to
you put it in there no it's not it's not
the kegel ball you put it like in your
thighs and then you squeeze it and it's
supposed to like engage
what is this
like that
uh-huh does it work
not my kegels like when i have to pee it
works yeah like you know that pee
feeling yeah you're like oh [ __ ]
and you suck it in uh-huh is this like a
specialty of yours
kegels gorilla griffin
um no i didn't know i had that title but
i'll take it
um we should probably introduce this
very special episode of this very
special very special well it comes every
four years so you're not gonna see us
like this for another four years and the
reason it's very special is because um
this week the olympics are happening i
watched the opening ceremony so this
episode of trash tuesday is dedicated to
the 2020 tokyo olympics and here we are
we should introduce what sport
we're representing i'm representing
allergies today um um okay i'll i'll
just go first
um so i am
the blonde wig is not necessarily
um olympic themed but i figured hey i'll
be something
i it made me look very american i'm a
gymnast and the gymnast store was out of
leotards so george got me a children's
ballet outfit i will text children i
would say you look a little bit more
like a figure skater tara lipinski oh
that's who i do a gymnast but it's we're
we're doing summer olympics winter
olympics is not for another two years
okay so um i really like this look
esther and i'm very proud of um
the
patriot athlete that you are thank you
geo you want to go next um so i am
representing
um all the weightlifters that are gonna
be competing um there isn't powerlifting
and this is for powerlifting but
uh weightlifting same same difference so
that's what i'm representing and i'm
gonna go ahead and say you look
like you would actually look like an
olympian do i you do no doubt
thank you i love you i want to see um
civilians in the olympics though then
i'll know how good meaning to say i
would love to see usain bolt or shikari
richardson and esther run the 100 meter
side by side
[ __ ] you
i saw that video of you running so i get
what you're talking about oh my god it
was fast but i think that she is a great
center of gravity and i do pull it off
i'm a i have balance i have decent i've
been taking more ballet classes i've got
bounce weight so what are you
oh okay so you don't look any different
than you normally do i have my
philippines team get up from when i
represented the philippines when i was
younger but gilbert has it for some
reason because he's trying to get it
replicated at a factory really um and i
try to get it back today it did not
happen does he need help with that i
could take it to my my clothing factory
he had he has it okay yeah thank you the
best sir
so today i am just going to be a swimmer
i should put my swim cap on
how would you do yeah
this way
i would have gone the other way yeah
that's a very wrong way okay i think so
you want to put the line to your
forehead like you need water in it no no
sometimes it's easier if you put talcum
powder but talcum powder is no longer um
we cancelled talcum powder right yeah
okay so you do this and you tuck it in
here
like so and do this you tuck it in like
and then
you twirl
the back of your hair
and you have so much hair this looks
like something sneak it in here that
would just make life more convenient as
a woman yeah
that was easy
it doesn't look it doesn't look great
it looks great wait wait until i pull my
goggles and tell me if i look like an
olympian
i mean i can't do have you tried putting
one on no horrible and then they pull
your hair that's what i would think it
would be sticking the hair and pulling
especially if it's an old cap and then
you put your goggles you never want to
put them backwards okay now you can
always tell who's not a swimmer by how
they put on their gear
did you put it on like this geo back and
forth for sure because it's easy no you
always want to put it well you can
either put it on your eyes first but
tell us why
because it's just the harder way to do
that look at what a little nerd you are
this is weird
this is the woman i like respect all day
at work it's like awesome this is who i
listen to okay hang on george tell me
where you going your mark and then beep
so you swim you shake why what are you
shaking for what's the shake for oh just
stretch i'm ready that looks so real
right she looks good okay
take your mark
what ah and then i lift up that is so
good can i show you my gymnast move yes
oh god blur out my thighs
you understand this little lawsuit wear
out my thighs
okay so this is what gymnasts do they
always go like this
[Laughter]
and that's all i have
do you want to see my best set up then
okay i'm gonna have to go on the floor
okay so this is when i set up for my
bench
it's [ __ ] dumb okay so the bench is
here
i get under the bar
and then i lift up this is just for the
youtube folks guys
yep and then i get out here
and then my legs are up here and i grab
the bar
and then i unrack it dude
i hope your husband is really hot
because you're so hot oh my god
gio what about when you do the regular
power lifting like the clean oh that's
weight lifting i don't do that so
powerlifting consists of um squat
bench and then a deadlift that's it
three movements you guys one time i was
at a dinner party actually with my
friend benji who i made the show alone
together with and this is before we made
the show
and we got invited to this dinner party
for this company that made that cleanse
called the clean program it was like
this really
fancy cleanse that like oprah did it
gwen is it clean with a k no no it's not
this was like maybe like eight or nine
years ago this was like the cleanse it
cost like five hundred dollars a really
big deal anyways i was very active on
the message boards and
got recognized
when i was working at press juicery one
of the the owners of the one someone who
worked for the company came in and was
like are you esther from and i was like
yeah cause she recognized me from the
message boards and then we became
friends and she invited me to a dinner
party
and it was all these like extremely like
it was like a out of a tv show like when
you're at a dinner party and like
everyone there is like really worldly
and interesting and like has something
going on and me and benjamin were like
and one of the guys at the dinner party
was like you know so yeah i'm a
scientist and
but a couple years ago i was like it
would be really great to be in the
olympics and so i trained and i uh i
went i actually went to wait let me
guess what sport
archery yes i was going to say that
and this is the moment where i actually
don't remember what sport it had
so i i shoot like a shot like shooters
it was something i never heard of so
probably was that well there's only
certain things like you can't be middle
aged and say i want to be a track star
or i want to be
it's one of those things that like gina
davis was represented the olympics in
archery gina davis like the actress oh i
know i don't really know if she did that
since birth
but that's one of the sports that you
can get to later on in life because
basketball yeah
you have to do it since like your age
two okay that makes me feel a little
better because it was definitely like a
defining moment for me in my 20s of like
oh so this this guy just like decided to
do the olympics and i'm just me like it
was just it made me feel
small
well i always felt small around
creatives like you because i wasn't
allowed a world outside of athletics and
swimming so when i would be around
people that were very talented on stage
or did anything outside of being an
athlete i was always so in awe
because i wasn't allowed to touch it to
even think about it to consider it to
join it
and so you know when um
so that feeling is mutual i think yeah
did you grow up playing sports at all
esther besides um ballet because i think
ballet is a [ __ ] sport and a half but
oh
amazing i think it is i'm really bad at
sports i did soccer for one like season
i know i was little and i was the only
kid i thought you were fast no no no no
what do you mean i was the only kid on
the team who didn't ever score
soccer ball no one wants to play with
her
i was the only kid on the team that's
really sad
i uh
and i
had an embarrassing thing where one day
we were having like a little team
meeting and i raised my hand and i was
like um so when do we get our costumes
and everyone laughed at me
and it was we got circles uniforms and
sports um football jerseys kits
but i was really bad like i like it was
really bad
no every other kid scored a goal except
for me and that i was i did it once and
was out maybe you were just a defender
and maybe you weren't positioned to
score i think it's also so boring you
just stand out in the field when you
cared about the way you looked you were
about the costume yeah you wanted to
perform yeah like when do we get our
when do i get my moment you know i would
get it i will go ahead and say your
height does not bode well for being a
defender
but i'm i i think that's where they put
you
yeah i was it was i was near the goal oh
and i always like let the other team
score like i was just so nice you got
out of their way it was like the
ultimate period in my life where i was
just like looking out at like not
[ __ ] focusing you know just being an
idiot did you guys well you're obviously
you were swimmer what about you did you
power lift as a kid no i just got into
that i know right um no i actually
danced and i did a lot of arts growing
up
um so like i played a ton of instruments
but not for a long time so i don't ever
really mention it because then people
are like oh what do you play
what what do you play so i let me fall
in love with you more no so i played
flute um i played guitar i played piano
i played um mandolin you know like those
yeah
yeah i played that and then i did ballet
and i did this like traditional mexican
dance called florico
um but i didn't stick to any of that and
then when i got into high school i
really got into drugs and i thought that
was really rad and then my grades
started getting really what drugs did
you get into
um so i really got into weed uh-huh i
was a big-time pod head and then i was
like oh [ __ ] there's cocaine cool let me
try that and i was like in high school
yeah i tried it once and then i tried to
ask it once and then i tried
crystal once crystal meth i think yeah
you did math geo i think so
like one time and then i was like oh
[ __ ] some of these are really cool like
let me just stop
and then i wanted to turn my life around
i did it
i didn't spiral downwards at any like
at all
um and then it was like uh i started
getting scouted
from my high school because i was really
tall i i think i've always been this
yeah so like do you want to play
basketball i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah let's
try that and um i didn't like contact
sports yeah i was a kid that like as
soon as i got the ball they rush and
they try to take the ball i'm like dude
just take it i don't want it just
[ __ ] take the ball and then um i
tried out for volleyball and then that i
loved it because there's no contact your
body was made for volleyball yeah
big butt tall
is that what you need a big butt you
need to be able to play volleyball yeah
i am also surprised like you but i were
wrong
kids in high school do coke um i think
not in my high school because we didn't
have that kind of money in my high
school we didn't either where did you
get coke like where do you get the money
for cocaine i don't know i we i just had
friends that had brothers and older
sisters and it was like you want to try
it oh but you're also a hot chick in
high school huh no i wasn't i was not
i don't even think i'm a hot chick now
well then you're wrong
sorry but i'd be rude no but i was not
like at all popular or like
i wasn't that person you know what's
crazy there's a girl that went to my
high school who was similar to you
really tall like on the she was a
basketball star
tall dorky like
you know whatever and then she graduated
high school and became a victoria's
secret model of course
and do leonardo dicaprio
yeah wait she's abdo no aaron heatherton
she's such a sweetheart i love her but
it's like it's those tall dorks that
they they just they trick you i didn't
do [ __ ] though like
i didn't become a victoria model or just
a model at all
but you could have been thank you i love
this room you guys are really nice
kalylah sometimes do you ever need like
when you go somewhere hype up music like
i get music in my ear and it just gets
me going like hyped up and if it's
really good sound quality it's all the
better
all the time i need it for life in
general at the gym
when i'm cycling all of it when the
world outside gets too loud something i
love to do is create my own soundtrack
by popping in my raycon wireless earbuds
sometimes you just need upbeat music to
pump you up before you see people or to
stay calm like with a guided meditation
or whatever what i love about these
raycons is that i have really sensitive
ears so i need a very specific type of
gel tip to go in there and i love the
comfort of the raycons i am when i just
came back from a long five hour flight i
had no
ear issues at all which i usually have
with other um
earbuds and raycons have a 32 hour
battery life so you can listen
to what you want when you want for like
a really long time and they start at
half the price of other premium audio
brands but they sound just as good like
that is insane to me and recons come
with a 45 day happiness guarantee so you
really can't lose give them a try you'll
see what we mean you guys create your
own soundtrack with raycon right now
listeners can get 15 off their recon
order at buy raycon.com
trash that's buy
raycon.com
trash to save 15 on recons by raycon.com
trash you guys my biggest conversation
starter in my life this year is liquid
death it's so weird it's like my whole
new personality i bring this everywhere
oh my god i was leaving work the other
night and i clicked one open
and
someone was like are you just drinking a
beer on your way to your car to drive
home from work and i was like oh no no
no um no it says water so liquid death
is literally mountain water in a can it
does it's a cool grill water drink yes
but here's why esther likes to give the
illusion of um
not being sober yeah i like to seem fun
right i'm not
but it's water and good for you you may
start noticing there are strange tall
boys of beers in the bottled water
section of your local stores well it's
not beer it's actually mountain spring
water from the alps and it's called
liquid death why is it called liquid
death ester
um because they're gonna brutally murder
your thirst and also their infinitely
recyclable tall boy cans are help
bringing death to plastic bottles
they also donate 10 of the profits from
every can sold to help kill plastic
pollution you can go to liquid.com
trash to get a free set of koozies with
your first order of any case of water or
just grab some at any whole foods or
7-eleven liquid death.com trash i love
both the mountain water and the
sparkling water is so bubbly crispy you
will it'll blow your mind
so i didn't realize that other kids in
school were doing cocaine like that to
me is so crazy and scary and then one
morning at school
this girl that i was friends with when i
did uh pom-poms but i hadn't talked to
her in like a year i ran into it you
know in the do you ever remember like
when you got to school
you'd like hang out in the cafeteria
before the day started you'd maybe some
people would buy breakfast you know what
i'm talking about
you're looking at me like i'm well i i
was sprinting from morning practice i
didn't have those liberties i was always
late to class i smelled like chlorine
all right sorry but that's what the cool
kids did you could tell me what the cool
kids did i think you're a cool kid no no
no
popular no i wasn't and they love
pom-poms pom-poms
yeah yeah that's the usually the popular
possibilities no no no no we were the
dorks so
this girl i hadn't seen her and she's
like hey i'm like so i'm like hey like
oh my god how have you been brittany
like i haven't seen you in so long she's
like i'm doing really well
um i'm i'm sober now like i quit coke
and i'm like that's amazing that's
really cool and like i'm 15 i've never
talked to someone who said that before
in my life so i
i just like for me the natural next
question was like oh like how long has
it been
or when was the last time you did it and
she's like this morning oh [ __ ]
and i was like okay i'm gonna go get
some a breakfast sandwich oh [ __ ] you
know bobby said that he started meth at
11. oh [ __ ] yeah i didn't know the kids
in poway
california were into that stuff well
where's poway it's like well in san
diego but he lived in like a country
club so they were like affluent kids
around so they had access to
just about everything wait bobby lived
in a country club yeah he grew up in
like he grew up well oh really yeah i
didn't know that mm-hmm it's what him
and i had in common
that's really weird so then did he also
lose it like you did he did yeah what
does lose it mean what's the it
well um bobby and i were both we both
come from like
affluent beginnings like when you were
like for me at least like my dad was
very you know was a wealthy man
but then around the age of 10
or 8 to 10 we lost it all so we went
from everything to like nothing one
bedroom cockroach infested home oh [ __ ]
bobby was didn't lose it quite like that
because i think that his parents still
did okay they still remained like middle
class i was broke the whole time oh yeah
where'd you grow up east l.a
yeah are you familiar with east la a
little bit do you know where the city of
commerce is yes okay like i was right on
the border line of commerce in east l.a
like it was just so hood that's where my
fiance goes to gamble yeah night long
yeah that's awesome oh my god or is it
bad no it's fine i don't okay but he
recently had to drive me to a
surgery at 5am and so his
his plan the night before was he
stayed up he went to commerce stayed up
all night and then drove me at 5am i was
like okay that's i guess that's romantic
that is romantic yeah wait dave is so
different from you
i know
it's crazy because he
went to
the winter olympics and actually went to
didn't he go watch it then you could
travel somewhere to watch no that was a
prank
what happened there wait what are you
talking about i in my head maybe i have
the wrong person in mind i thought that
dave went to some winter olympics and
watched it there should we call him and
see like as him participated or was it
a spectator i thought he traveled
somewhere i feel like he did as a prank
and i don't know if i'm right or if
you're thinking of someone else
sometimes my memory does not serve me
well well let's see
my little gambling prankster
hello hi dave
yes esther hi
did you go to the winter olympics
did i go to the winter olympics as a
spectator as a spectator
no i did not did you do a prank where
you pretended you went to the winter
olympics i did but i wouldn't really
consider it a prank okay well you
pranked kalila and now it's coming back
to bite you in the ass two years later
cause you're
in trouble but i thought i was being
obvious because i like took pictures it
was like i took a picture of like uh
like this here on tv or something well i
guess kalila is just a big dummy then
all right love you bye
wow i can't believe you remember that
and it it stuck with you i downloaded
into my heart and dave is an adventurous
person because he went with a friend
without esther to watch the winter
olympics well but the thing is is he
would do something like that so you're
right like and he's a big traveler he
he's yeah
but i am not like that i love that you
guys address each other by your first
name
just to like what is that i know i love
why you weren't sure if that's who
you're calling dave
i always we're very formal like
i don't know well how does this sex
initiation happen oh my god like um are
you ready to go into the bedroom and on
a dress yes oh no like how do you i
don't know how do you do it how do i do
it um
don't flip it on me i asked you first
wait i do want to know geo um so our sex
life has changed a lot now it's like i
just want to [ __ ] and then we were just
like oh [ __ ] let's go yeah i feel like
it's more like
hey should we should we
meet me there
right that's like i like me in that room
i do like that approach i think that um
bobby and i are having um
an issue with
not laughing like
everything is a joke in the house so
it's hard to get into the mood because
if i were to initiate and say something
like
or do anything like that he would laugh
or if he were to do the same i would
laugh and then the feeling is gone
there's no sense of seriousness and i
feel like we need that i the same issue
really yes
i am the perpetrator though exclusively
like i just like try to be funny or like
like with that one like the one of the
times where we role played like i
twisted it into like that i was robbing
him like
just kidding i'm here to rob you like it
just makes how did it start though was
it like hey how did how did you walk
into my house
is it like that it was like hey i'm
prepped down the street like i've just
been loose in the neighborhood and i
need somewhere to go
are you like a puppy
no i wasn't but that is an interesting
pitch
um for our lives um
but i i know i'm like you like it's
it's
i'm still very like silly and almost
like child like with like i'm immature
about it i think that's what it is bobby
and i are
so immature
that um
it takes away
the sexual energy it just zaps it from
the room it just robs the room because
we're just so stupid yeah
like how do you do that and even when
we're touching each other we're still
giggling and laughing i'm like oh we
suck at this have you guys done any
interesting unique role plays lately
that you can enlighten us with i think
nothing can beat
you know the shoemaker scenario
bobby makes me a clogs maker from like
the 1700s what is hot about that so he's
an aristocrat and i go door to door
and i offer him different designs of
clogs are you naked when you're doing
this no no no i'm a i'm a professional
she's well dressed i'm well-dressed okay
i'm like a very very revered shoemaker
do you have the costume or you're just
in this clothing but then i just use
your imagination oh yeah i don't have
the amount it's just all imaginations
but we really buy into we buy in hard
what is hot about it he's not him and
i'm not me that's what's hot about it
it's like i am completely like
i'm not kalila
you know
and he's sir brandon from so and so
yeah and that's i think that's what
makes it
i i'm not sure if it's the healthy
approach but we'd rather [ __ ] other
people so we become other people i think
that is healthy i think that's the most
healthy is just saying it flat out and
then like how do we address it and then
you just do it unfortunately when he
gets down there it's the same hairy
[ __ ]
see every time he's like wow no matter
who it is they all have hairy [ __ ]
what are have you guys role played
lately
no we haven't role-played lately but i'm
really would it esther you give me a
scenario and i promise you i will test
it out with bobby
geo you give me one you give me one who
am i who is he and i promise you hand on
heart that i will give it a go
i mean i'll just go with the cliche one
um
um you're
uh his secretary okay and you just
didn't meet your deadline and he's
pissed
and he's just gonna give it to you wait
what does he do for a living he's a
crypto uh
guy
he does that for a living
um and you were supposed to submit some
reports yeah and you sound like you've
never had a job
she used to be a she used to work in a
bank
you should know this stuff geo
you had to submit reports yeah i like
the [ __ ] analytics you know what
reports i'm talking about don't act like
you don't know what i'm talking about
you know the reports yeah they need
reports and how does he punish me um
he's gonna bend you over yeah desk yeah
and you're getting punished from behind
he's like why didn't you submit the
[ __ ] data on time twice i have the
same hairy [ __ ]
or have i shaved this day yeah no you
have to shave all right yeah it has to
be smooth it has to be different okay
yeah yeah i'm down for that i can give
that a go i'll tell you how how that
works with
with a kryptos i can give them a whole
list so aav
snx it's not working out for me yeah go
ahead esther bobby is
a he's down on his luck
okay and he is uh
he he's you know he's a waiter
and he's just kind of lonely and then
you're a ghost
and you
you're like i am the ghost and i'm here
to make your life better what would you
like to do a ghost mom then
a ghost mentor okay
and then but how would he feel any type
of pleasure
having sex with a translucent you sound
like you've never been alive
or had sex
i think a ghost is a role play i just
haven't heard about you know i think you
guys here's the opportunity with bob and
clyde like they will go there
i love what you just did
because i went like super like normal
kind of boring which was hot the other
way it's like there and they gave them a
scale to pick from they're the the
people to experiment with
they'll do it yeah they really will we
will reenact the scene from deer hunter
you know what i mean vietnam
bloodied ups like soldiers i can be a
dude like hot yeah yeah so who do i
report to after i do these this this
podcast audience okay yeah okay so
you'll give it to bobby in her scenario
and then in my scenario bobby gives it
to you the ghost is the pow
that's not really the artist's original
intention but oh let's not flip it give
it to her how you want to give it to her
i think that like you're the ghost and
you're just like whatever you want to do
today okay and then he's like a like
kind of a
how did i die
oh very important to
the storyline
i
think that actually
your death had something to do with
bobby's character and that's why you're
sort of there in his life
um but in part two we'll find out how
you died oh maybe he's better like rat
poisoning on accident like he didn't
even know he served it to her yeah
because he's a bad waiter oh he did it
on purpose oh yes he has done that he
has he's poisoned you well no he's on
purpose i think like in his job back in
the day he like put a roach in the
coffee grinder i've heard that one yeah
because he was really angry she was the
customer and i was a customer and i died
from some type of cockroach plague
and then now i'm taking revenge so i
will
i will bait him into sex but i'm gonna
rip his dick off his body out i like it
and then make make him put it in the
coffee grinder oh god it took a dark
turn this is like sounding like how you
play with your barbies
like okay
lisa alone
well uh speaking of food we have our
foods from japan right now so uh
what
extra game uh with this one if uh for
one of the dishes so uh
we'll let esther go first just for fun
uh choose your color of uh
oh [ __ ] we're eating [ __ ] choose your
color choose your color you don't get to
touch it until it's pink all right you
want the pink one yeah
and oh what is that what is that esther
i i don't know show it to me
it's organic and vegan
ew is it natto i oh i can't dig no
no no no no it's not
esther this is uh this is in honor of
japan but
if you natto is rough if you do well in
this game esther you don't have to eat
that is that how it goes george just eat
it
you got this
did i pick the worst one like the next
one like mochi or something only one way
to find out let me tell it put it to you
this way natto doesn't taste bad it just
feels bad and it looks gnarly as [ __ ] a
little snotty it's super snotty dude
yeah
all right behind the line right there
one chance for a five oh my gosh esther
you
give her the pep talk to your team
captain okay all right baby girl you got
this look at no look at me
you
can do no you can do this let's go okay
you got this you have to point your toes
do the gymnastic twirl twirls do you
have it but like i don't even know how
this use two hands esther
you no i believe in you you got this
when you throw it when you throw it
you're not looking at what you're
throwing you're looking straight at the
target what do you want to hit and keep
your eyes on that and let your hands
follow through no i say you just close
your eyes
[Laughter]
you'll get it trust me aim high and like
let it arch i believe in you i believe
in you you got this i'm so scared i
can't throw it
that was so good that was so close
that was so close kind of hit the five
and bounced is it even possible though
to make it because maybe george is
setting us up
uh i think that why don't we all open
the food and then we'll eat it
esther to make you feel better i have
drunkenly thrown a dart that's someone's
chest before what the [ __ ] well it just
happened to be
oh
that's a three
george you eat the [ __ ] natto i will
i got an extra one here
i'll eat it with you if it makes you
feel better yeah but wait what did you
get do you want to know
what candy is
what is this what is goya that is the
secret of uh
long life in okinawa here's a knife to
cut it up with it's a bitter melon
oh i love ampa yeah we call it it's
bitter melon how do i cut this
here give me the natto would you like to
at least try it esther
um it is african-american vegan uh how
much are you vegan organic and vegan now
before you'll uh
give it a go and you love natto you said
you like it no no but i made a mistake
once of thinking that i really do eat
everything and anything oh yuck that
stinks too here we'll just open one then
and we'll share that one do i just bite
this yeah
kalila's lollipop is good yeah i don't
think i don't think you have to eat it
but you're not a [ __ ] is that what
you're saying i'm not a [ __ ] gio are
you challenging me too because i'm not a
[ __ ] either
i know i'm not a [ __ ] either i'm a
[ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
coco what is that
natto oh it's all over your mic
girlfriend oh [ __ ] it's still in my god
look it doesn't taste bad the
consistency is just you know
ooey gooey hair pass it yeah
i'm not a [ __ ]
i'm not a [ __ ] how many little balls
did you eat [ __ ] it i'm doing okay let's
go
let's go
it's like cheesy looking
[Laughter]
strings
okay it's our favorite sponsor hello
magic spoon one of my most prized meals
that i eat after a busy day
magic spoon i freaking love you you look
we're all trying to eat better but
healthy breakfast
doesn't have to be boring because magic
spoon has the amazing flavors you love
but without all the bad stuff the fruity
flavor i'm obsessed you guys i've been
trying to cut down on carbs sugar all
the unhealthy stuff but you know that i
still have that taste i need it i need
the taste that's why i have magic spoon
probably three times a week and growing
up cereal was like the best part of
being a kid
i don't want to lose that okay i'm
already like getting old i don't need to
also lose the joys from my youth magic
spoon has 0 grams of sugar
to 14 grams of protein and only 4 net
grams of carbs in each serving only 140
calories a serving it's keto-friendly
gluten-free grain-free soy-free and
low-carb you can build your own box or
get a variety pack with available
flavors such as cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry and cinnamon and
pro tip
if you mix the cocoa with the peanut
butter you have peanut butter cups wait
magic spoon is also bringing back two
super popular flavors the cookies and
cream and the maple waffle
permanently you guys should make sure
you get these again and try them for the
first time because they're delicious and
indulgent go to magicspoon.com
tuesday to grab your delicious meal and
try it today and be sure to use our
promo code tuesday at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com tuesday and use the code
tuesday to save five dollars off thank
you magic spoon for sponsoring this
episode
i think this is
come on you gotta try it you should try
it this is so [ __ ] up this is like
abuse no it's nice
we all did it
i really okay what does it make you feel
better
they're kind of lentily like lentils it
smells bad you guys it doesn't smell bad
yes it does and then it has an
aftertaste of like a little bit of
coffee
i can't do the smell like esther you
love everything japanese i'm gagging i'm
gagging i'm gagging from the smell i'm
dying from the smell i'm gagging i'm
dying i'm not here i have like a vomit
gag oh my god it's happening again it's
just fermented soybeans no but you know
the lollipop what is the smell what is
that smell soy bean have you smelled
durian or stinky tofu we had dorian here
didn't i i think i lost that game yeah
have you tried stinky tofu
i can do stinky tofu i can't do it tofu
and it smells like literal human feces
yeah that has been sitting in your car
for like 20 years
it is pretty rough i think i prefer
human feces to natto
the smell smell-wise
do you want me to give you some human
feces i mean i smell it every day so
it's like i'm more familiar and calm
it's more i feel like we can tolerate
our own [ __ ] versus other like i can
smell my [ __ ] all day
but if i smell like someone else's [ __ ]
i don't want to smell that yes my farts
don't really aren't nasty though
i think that's why or maybe i just think
that because they're mine but i never
really feel as though like there are i
know some people have very like
heavy on the protein
bar my husband rough
it's like the the cloud sticks to the
wall
he has to fan out his [ __ ] pants to
get it out because it clings onto the
fabric one time i had a really big crush
on this boy named michael
and he played football
and the first time that he actually paid
attention to me i smelled a fart trapped
in jeans
and i could not view him any other way i
hate that smell
turn you off from a person forever so
fast and forever forever you've um
brought this up before the topic of
super smellers mm-hmm it's been a
problem in my life me too you guys are
both super smellers yes it is like the
biggest source of my anxiety is smelling
things
it's like i'm so jealous of people who
don't smell stuff because i feel like i
would be a happier person if i didn't i
think so too like here's another one of
my smelling triggers is if i walk into
an elevator with people and a smell of
scalp oh my god i know what you're
talking about it automatically puts me
in a bad like headspace scalp scalp and
i know it's really weird to say
like someone's head someone's head i
don't like the smell of head
i don't know
so and what happens how it manifests
into anxiety is that i wash my head
three times a day
and
it's a problem because i don't like the
smell of head
does that make sense no esther you're a
super smelly you should you should
understand
what's the smell that you just that
people other people don't usually care
about that you care about
fire
why is that a joke
i like well i just like came out with
the most like like
my most triggering anxiety
and everyone is literally like falling
out of their chairs people often run at
the smell of fire oh
so you're saying just like a backyard
barbecue would trigger you
yes like any kind of
i guess smoke smell like people are like
oh i love the smell of a fireplace or
like a barbecue no like that smell i i
can't think about anything else other
than that smell like where is it coming
from what is it like what are people
doing who's doing it
that is a really bad one any kind of
like chemically smell that i don't know
what it is that's to me the biggest
thing it's like if i don't know what the
source of a smell is i will go crazy and
i i know i've talked to people i know
whitney cummings has this but not with
smell
with
i think it's with sound
like that's a common one i think like
people like i hear something i can't
stop or like or like they can't sleep
unless it's pitch black like they have
like little things for me it's always
smell like if i smell something and i
don't know what it is i can't focus on
anything else other than does the
anxiety come from the fact that um if
you were able to identify it would you
be less anxious
yeah if someone told you esther this is
the smell of black mold and you'd be
like okay black mold now i know what it
is
that's an interesting example you
presented
it will kill you i don't know if that
applies
um
i don't i yeah i think it helps but it
just kind of depends on the case um
because there's a woman
that um
that researchers are actually working
with and she's considered to be a super
smeller but she can smell parkinson's
early onset parkinson's in people even
before the symptoms how and how it
happened was she fell in love with a man
and who was the love of her life but
like about 10 years in when they were in
their 30s
she was repulsed suddenly by the way he
smelled and she was like nothing has
changed
now i can't even be around this guy
without feeling repulsed by a certain
smell that he's giving off wow and it
turns out that there is a chemical
change in your body that happens when
you have parkinson's that gives off a
smell that she is able to detect in
people
and now they're working with her and
other super smellers because they're
linking
like you know this guy wasn't even
symptomatic yet until later on his life
but she was able to know
the scent of early parkinson's holy so
you might be a mutant x-men i feel like
i i genuinely believe that i could do
that like i'm not even kidding i think i
if she can do it i believe i could do it
yeah i believe i could smell what she's
smelling what makes you a super smelly
like what
indicators are like what the hell like
you ever go into like for instance me
and my niece or bobby they can't smell
[ __ ] i'm smelling and i go around little
like
drives me crazy but
i will we have a couch and i will smell
every single inch of it looking for a
scent that i can't pin i'm like there is
a smell somewhere here and they're like
you're going crazy and i'm like no it's
a scent of something and i'm smelling
and i'll go around the house searching
for what the source of the smell
and um i usually find it and they're
like oh you were right yeah or if there
is an accident because we have a puppy
let's say
i could smell it even before i walk
through the door
like there is and
maybe that's because i have a really big
nose
i mean a long nose maybe this is a very
very um efficient instrument i don't
think it's to do with that but
um but yeah i can smell things ahead of
time and before anyone can detect it and
it drives me [ __ ] crazy but i don't
think super smeller is like something
that like scientific you know like it's
not like oh i'm double jointed like it's
this or that i
i just have noticed
throughout my life that i smell
everything i smell things people don't
smell like it's a smell to you no not at
all also forgotten also b.o doesn't
bother me she loves she loves it it's
actually very comforting to me because i
know
i'm like oh i know what that is that's
just a person like that's not going to
hurt me yeah just at the green glance i
actually wonder this was because i've
talked about this with whitney a lot and
she always talks about like ancestral
trauma and like how
she has things that happen back like in
her family that have that like affect
her
and
i wonder if my
my mom was like anxious or something and
that is probably what passed on to me
the anxiety yeah i was i think that's
probably what totally and yeah well
that's not even passed down during
pregnancy that's just passed down from
like living with someone who's anxious
because like even my mom all of her [ __ ]
like you know all she would always
outwardly talk about planes crashing so
like my whole life i've always been like
oh anytime i'm on a plane i'm like
goodbye
i had that too for a long time because
when i was little my sister i had the
meanest like bullying sister one time we
were flying and right when the plane was
about to take off she turned to me and
she's like you know sometimes when
planes take off they just blow up and
everyone dies
and that has never left me that's
exactly what my mom would say what yeah
plane crashes were a big topic in my
household all the time
i just got that i just got this fear of
uh flying and dying like recently really
like that before at all before or after
you had a kid after but i i don't even
think it has anything to do with me
leaving him behind i am a professional
fear of flying
er let me give you my advice okay wait
did you get over it though yes okay i'm
not scared of flying at all anymore and
i was very very very scared for like
a long time
two things one if you're on a flight and
you feel turbulence that has absolutely
nothing to do with the safety of a plane
so now when there's turbulence and bumps
i just enjoy it i enjoy the ride why
does it have anything to do with it
because it's like there's a i don't know
the exact reason but it has to physics
it's like it's literally like if you're
driving in a car and you just drive over
a bump
it's just like that it's not gonna cost
it can't it doesn't affect the safety of
the plane it will not cause a crash it
will not
affect the mechanics of the plane it's
just going to it's just like if you
drove on a bumpy road okay it's very
like that
in terms of being afraid of a crash when
you get on a plane
you have to think about
how many planes take off and land around
the world every single day every hour
of the day are so many play the odds
what are the odds that when all day
every day hundreds if not thousands of
planes are taking off and landing why
would you end up on one that's randomly
just going to crash all of a sudden play
the odds it's just not you're not it's
not going to happen
that that i'm going to add a number
three to that okay which really helped
me as watching the weather channel
was um
in order to categorize hurricanes you
know how they do it they send a plane up
there that is [ __ ] to measure in the
[ __ ] eye of the storm and around it
is there a person in this plane yeah
it's a person it's like a plane that's
supposed to pick up weather data and so
planes are safer
in air than on the ground that's why i
think when hurricane the one in puerto
rico happened they were trying to get
all planes off of the airport tarmac
tarmac tarmac yeah yep because they're
safer up in the air even in severe
weather what the [ __ ] why
they're built they're built to fly right
they're built to be in the clouds to
handle the turbulence to do all of that
so i'm like if a plane can be in a
category 5
storm and gather all this data then i'm
fine you're not it's not gonna yeah
you're so right the other thing
is i always think facts and money
there's so much money riding on like the
business of air travel that those
companies will do whatever the [ __ ] it
takes to not have a crash because that
will be so bad for business optics so i
get all this okay i understand it
logically yeah
as soon as i feel this [ __ ] plane
move i'm like oh my god i'm gonna
[ __ ] die
wait but have you guys a question for
you after have you ever flown spirit
airlines yes [ __ ] that because that
yeah i thought i was over my fear of
flying and i used i took a flight to
vegas once on spirit
and that should brought me back to the
base
what are you guys saying because just
because the airline is cheaper doesn't
mean that the [ __ ] turbulence is
weird yes i have a theory have you flown
the spirit no what's your theory because
here's my theory is that some airlines
when they feel the turbulence they're
like yeah
pilots out there please correct me if
i'm wrong they're like
we're willing to spend a little bit more
fuel to rise up above the turbulence
and i don't think philippine airlines or
spirit airlines does this because they
go right through terms of like we don't
have
the firewall to waste the budget for
this
that's a okay that theory is pretty good
and i do want to know if that's true
i've never had a nice calm flight on
spirit airlines are you is that really
true i swear to you and they're always
late oh yeah days later being late [ __ ]
you should we take a banana break yes
let's take a banana what's going on with
bananas
[Music]
um geo on this show when um when
feelings are heightened and emotions are
um are high
we take our potassium break
i do have sweaty palms just thinking
about this flight that i'm not i haven't
booked yet
but that's just you and i are the same
in that way it's just irrational fear
you can't intellectualize yourself
that's true but anxiety and it makes
sense it's like i always do think like
well we are just little animals so like
we're we're not meant to be up in the
sky so it makes sense that we're scared
okay thank you guys
i appreciate this
but you get into this
metal contraption called a car every day
oh and i'm trying to die
what i'm trying to go fast i'm trying
not to be late but i'm in control yeah
that's that's a yeah so if i was flying
the plane i don't give a [ __ ] what the
people in the backfield
can you show them because they're scared
if you're flying it
off i'll work for spirit i don't give a
[ __ ] we're going through the [ __ ]
hurricane you said that you live in
vegas i'm i've been curious my whole
life what the [ __ ] is it like living in
vegas i know you know you there briefly
like okay what do you imagine it to be
like because i think that's more
interesting is there
what do i think my life okay i think you
wake up and like
far in the distance you see the
glimmering lights of the vegas strip so
in the daytime all these lights are
really bright yeah okay and you're like
it's right over it's just right outside
town we can dip in whenever we want but
you try to go about your daily life and
get your cup of joe
and
head to work but you're always a little
distracted by the glimmering lights
across the way
and sometimes you give in to temptation
and you head on over and you have a you
have a time a fun time
with who like gambling with like shows
hookers you walk the strip
you stop at cvs you get a bottle of
water
and you
walk through the casinos and you just
kind of take it all in like wow
i live here this is my home
you're not far off really yeah you're
really not far off so i definitely wake
up and i could see the strip but it's
true really far away yeah i can see this
trip am i psychic to speak yeah i think
you are i think i gave you all the
information
um i do and i look at that and then um i
don't want to be anywhere near the strip
though because it's trash
it's yucky and it's icky and there's
drunk people and there's
but like i live in super suburban like
family town so it's really cool filled
with parks and it's really [ __ ] hot
and it's the backdrop is
quite beautiful it is you
have red rocks basically like you have
such great hiking there nature's great
there it's like a beautiful desert
that's my backyard the red rocks that
sounds really actually nice to me how do
you tolerate like the 120 degree days
well it's not i didn't realize how humid
california was like it's thick air out
here and i was born and raised here so i
just never thought anything of it i was
always like oh [ __ ] like my hair is
always curly out here um and then i go
to vegas for like a few months and my
[ __ ] boogers are all rusty and bloody
and dry and like my skin's [ __ ] up i
look 10 years older because it's dry as
[ __ ] and then i come back here
um and it's really thick air so it could
be 80s or 90s out here and i can't i
can't stand it but out there because
it's super dry it just feels like you're
in like a sauna
and you can like tolerate it
so i'll deal with that 120 degrees and
really 90 out here yeah
i have for some reason i just have this
imaginary version of my life in my head
where i live in vegas and i'm i'm a
dancer and i do
what kind of dance well i take ballet
class in the morning because i'm serious
about my art but then at night then
during the day i auditioned to be in one
of the big vegas reviews
and
you know i go watch the big vegas dance
shows because i
dream of one day being in one so i'm
like an aspiring dancer in my dream
i have a question for you guys since
we've all been with our partners for a
really really long time right are there
any moments where you want to test if
you still got it yes
i feel like that's something maybe that
no one wants to admit to
but we all feel like we put ourselves in
situations and you walk away and you're
like i still got it oh i am highly
desired i am highly desired still oh i
don't know anymore i thought inside
because i'll sometimes i'll be like
like for example all if i get my makeup
didn't work the first thing i want to do
is just get it off my face but then like
like when i'm done but then sometimes
i'll be like well
i'll just keep it on so that the and see
if dave is like extra nice to me tonight
or something like i'll do those kinds of
things or like i'll put on like the
cuter outfit around the house just to be
like
see if i feel like i still got it but
you're saying like flirt with a guy not
even flirt just put yourself in a
position to possibly get flirted with oh
i love that i want to do that and we
should we should all three of us go
somewhere and see if we still got it i
want to do this first of all i never had
it i've never flirted with a stranger
but i want to see if i can do it what
the [ __ ] are you guys talking about of
course you have it like you got it well
i don't i wanna kiss you not down
like you got it thank you geo yeah you
guys got it for sure so i don't need
outside esther maybe we don't need extra
i mean if you want to have fun do it
i just for me i'm just like i hate
people
so i'm like don't even [ __ ] look at
my parents
that's me
like i want to know if we're let's say
we're in vegas and we're in the
chandelier bar at the cosmo right i just
wonder if i'm going to get hit on my
[ __ ] trolls and gargoyles or if a
nice you know handsome gentleman will
approach me like i don't know like what
kind of god i got
that one i do like like what's your pool
yeah like what's my point is that i
don't know anymore because i've been
i've been with someone since
28 years old is my pool at 36 the same
as 28. gotcha i want to do that one i
want to test what my pool is because i
always get gargoyles and trolls
all the time and i want the fine guy
that's [ __ ] rich and he's like you
see that [ __ ] rolls royce out there
you want to have a good night like
that's the guy i want i never had that
how about this how about this we just
honk the horn you say dave this is very
innocent
you say bart just you know he's let me
have and then i just want to see
yeah he won't care dave would not care
so i wouldn't care either and then we
can assess we can
we can statistically assess it after
it's like geo got three gargoyles
i'm so down can we record this yes i'm
super down what can we wear like or do
we have any limits cause like if i'm if
i were come [ __ ] me now outfit like for
sure oh it's gonna be a come [ __ ] me now
oh yeah are you kidding it has to be
roll out and [ __ ] you know what i
mean dungarees
i'm gonna be like a 10 out of 10 in my
eyes yeah as 10 as i can get i will be
10.
i it's funny you say rolls royce because
i am actually so turned off by nice cars
that on my first date with dave
i saw his car and it was a 2002 um
civic honda civic and i was like
i love this guy
i [ __ ] love this guy he's a badass
why
because
he's not driving some flashy car he's
not trying to impress anybody he's not
throwing his money away he just doesn't
it's like you know what it is like he
you're so confident that you don't give
a [ __ ] but what if he's like a really
like he's an enthusiast of like muscle
or like the would you still have been
with him if he rolled up in like
uh
a lambo it would have been so tacky to
me but he's the same exact person he
just drives a lambo he's like esther you
know my dad he passed on this love for
cars down to me most likely i'd still be
with him because we you know it worked
but that i just would be so turned it
would be a genuine turn off to me wow
genuinely a turn off are you what about
you i'm um
i once made out with a long bearded man
who drove up to my house in a vespa so
that should tell you all you need to
know i have no
i just really i i have taken
yeah like and i remember his beard
smelled like the food he just ate oh i
knew exactly what he ate i was like oh
he's had some pizza and wings
um and i still did it because it's just
i have no standards really
i'll do i'll do anything i'll do
i'll just do period yeah i'll do it all
i like them all that's good i like that
yeah if you if if you've got a good
inside you make me laugh yeah that's all
i care about either suck your dick all
day same yeah hoco
yes so are we gonna we're gonna play the
pole game then where would where what's
where do we go i'm not going to commerce
in that casino we got to go high end
like
arya
win arya we're we're gonna do go these
days i don't know cause we go to the new
one i want to go to resorts world the
new one oh okay we'll follow where she's
go she's the trench you know the trendy
stuff we'll come visit you geo yeah
we're just going to tell we're just
going to tell bart is this this in a
sense he doesn't give a [ __ ] i don't
have to tell him either i know he'll be
like oh can i watch you guys do it yeah
he'd bobby would be like go get with him
leave him say
do me a favor that's what he would tell
me too
let me know if you liked anything he did
and then i'll try it
he doesn't care i know
like sometimes i threaten bobby i'm like
i'm going dancing i'm going to grind up
on some dick he's like please please do
he said get that energy out of the way
god damn yeah that's part two he's like
yeah we should like you should totally
[ __ ] other people and then tell me what
you like are you serious yeah no he
doesn't yeah for sure and i'm like no
that's just weird i don't want to do
that
no because i don't want you [ __ ]
other people what the hell
yeah i have to do um i'm on a show where
i have a love interest this year
i know wait do you have to kiss yes he
kissed me
he kissed me it was so weird like
i
it was weird how does it feel and how
does dave really feel the the actor
playing my love interests he's this guy
um
jason
oh no don't say momoa no if you say
so his name's jason blair and
he is really he's super professional
he's such a good actor he's really tall
and handsome i'm not really into him
right like he's i like him he's super
nice he's super good looking like i love
working with him but i'm he's not like a
guy that i'm like
you know into but then when we did the
scene and he kissed me so confidently i
was like
what's a confident kiss feel like
whenever i have a kissing scene
i'm
um
i'm really nervous and i'm really giddy
and like weird
and so i'm like man like don't do it
like
and he just like like went in and like
gave me like a giant smooch i was like
oh
okay and i told dave i was like my
co-star kissed me today and he's like
okay
then just like what are we having for
dinner
who doesn't care
do they teach you how to kiss no there's
no lessons wait do you talk amongst each
other and say hey i'm gonna go left you
go right
no and i didn't even know there was a
kiss in that scene like i think it had
gotten added or something like
or i think i just i missed that it was
in there so i was really caught by
surprise and which was better for me
because like i said when i know the kiss
is coming i'm like
but he just kissed me like
a man kissed me i mean ultimately that's
the only good memories i have of being
single it's never sex with other people
it's always
making out yeah making out is always the
best memory i have i'm like oh god like
if you could bottle that i could drink
an elixir every day
that's you i agree
and i'm famously a bad kisser that's
what dates you a bad kisser i get too
excited
and i just tongue down
oh that's like bobby yeah i kiss like
i'm in junior high bobby is a junior
high kisser too oh yeah you don't like
that that's the slobber right well he
just goes in too hard too fast and i i
like a slow lippy kiss yeah i don't i
like to just go crazy and dave is always
like
yeah like when he first kissed like you
were really excited
[Music]
it was i was like was it bad he's like
yeah
wait do you guys still make out with
your partners yes so for me my our whole
relationship kind of went backwards so
when we first got together we were anal
really
absolutely we started off [ __ ] in the
ass no
um we really liked each other and it was
like this soul connection like right
away so then like the first month we
were together it was like i love you we
lived together already and then we
started working together and then our
relation our romantic relationship kind
of disappeared for like five years so
then we kind of went backwards so now
it's like we're kind of dating all over
again oh that's sweet yeah so that's
when you're asking about role playing
all that stuff i'm like well we're
barely getting comfortable [ __ ] each
other right now like going yeah i want
to [ __ ] you like that's like where we're
at yeah wow yeah you're like judging me
like no i think that's cute i'm jealous
that is really cute yeah we're going
backwards right i think it's so easy to
forget that
that's not just your
to think of them in a romantic way is
really a challenge because you're like
nope he's my best friend he's my
business partner he's somebody that i
can trust super you know yeah i go to
him with my problems right right well
and you watch him [ __ ] and you watch him
pick [ __ ] out of his nose yeah you see
all the nasty side so after a while
you're like it's not that hot he pays
the water bill like it's just kind of
practical
that's how i have always it's very it's
been very easy for me to stay loyal
is that
i am so sure that whoever i lust for on
the side is simply a fantasy because
that person picks their nose shits the
same way
is just as disgusting and there is no
greener pasture it just simply isn't
it's very true same
yeah [ __ ] so still willing to play the
pool game in vegas we're still going to
resorts world yeah with
resorts world cleavage up and out yep
yep i'm down okay we have um george has
prepared a quick uh olympics quiz time
game i don't know [ __ ] about the
olympics all right perfect then we'll
start with you geo let's go
wait we're working as a team though this
is the olympics in the olympics they're
so angry
it is your eyebrows
well it's pushing the [ __ ]
you're smiling and i'm pissed at the
same time okay i'll keep it like this
i'll keep it like this i thought now
that was extreme competition okay go geo
first okay yeah okay anybody can steal
this if she gets it wrong for sure take
it when was the olympics held in los
angeles your choices are
1904 1932 1984 or 1996.
84 final answer los angeles no it wasn't
okay chance mustillo well was it 96. no
no no it's in 1984 is los angeles
because 1996 was in georgia and atlanta
yeah 96 in atlanta i was going to say
that yes esther we're both barbie
yes
esther and i are correct 1996. right the
barbie version yeah wait you just did
1996 but i said 84. no that 96. you're
correct gotcha that was like atlanta
ninety-seven surgery's [ __ ] with me
we're punishing with me now we gotta
punish you you don't have the answers i
know the answer is 1932. ah it was 1932.
no it's 1984. was it the first one
you're saying
because 1992 was barcelona and then
athens and then sydney how do you know
that i'm sorry it's no it's 1992 it's
barcelona and then there's um atlanta
and then sydney and then athens and then
beijing
yeah why do you know this because my
whole life has just circled around
wanting to be in the olympics
cutouts of all of the olympics because
that's my one big dream
that didn't
happen but you're an olympian in my
heart thanks geo
i love you i'm gonna be an olympic [ __ ]
in vegas oh [ __ ] yeah
now esther how many rings are in the
olympic symbol
we are still rolling guys just in case
you're listening and you she's going
straight
five
did you help her okay oh i was gonna say
six what clyde was at five all right uh
six did anybody want to steal that one
i'm gonna go ahead and say five [ __ ] it
totally is five because it's three on
top blue yellow black green red all
right i'm gonna give that that one yeah
you really know
it's my whole life jill
name three gymnastics events
oh floor uneven bars balance beam
all right we're back to geo who [ __ ] is
this
i don't know but he knows how to have a
good time oh is it ryan lochte is it
ryan locked down it is a good guess
because he is uh
and still be wrong michael phelps
okay
was that michael phelps that's not
michael phelps that's michael
he's hot dude ryan locked he's so hot
but he like threw his he like went down
the down the drain because he dumbed
them
he did some dumb things in brazil in rio
yeah he was a dick all right now to
esther what sport is due to the tokyo
olympics isn't it i know that one guys
why did you just watch it yesterday
a new olympic sport yeah uh it's been a
sport in existence for a very long time
usually in the extreme setting
think extreme sports
i think extreme thinking karate sport
jumping
karate jumping by mma no extreme extreme
sports she said it though right no she
didn't she did it oh he's one of the new
ones
yeah what's that one skateboarding
really yeah i'm gonna change a brake
dancer
break dancing yeah isn't break dancing
anyone geo you're you're you're making
the [ __ ] making that [ __ ] up why are
like the why is it so hot to me like the
thought of like the olympic like michael
phelps or ryan lochte but like like a
few years after when their lives are in
shambles like that's so hot michael
phelps life is not in shambles because
he has like
just had his like fourth kid and he's
gonna kill him yeah um but you know
what's really hot to me olympic village
think about living there with all the
athletes from all over the world and if
you're single and
your event is done and you can just [ __ ]
around yep and you're [ __ ] with like
roman gods and then you never have to
see him again yeah oh yeah wasn't there
an olympics where they like ran out of
condoms
i possibly i i believe that because
athletes it's like we're so hyper
focused on just our sport that it's like
yeah as soon as your event's done yeah
god that feeling is so good all right
kalila who is this
[Music]
um
icon
australian indigenous
from the australian indigenous kathy
freeman she is the 400 800 olympic
champion of the 2000 olympics in sydney
god damn and she was one of the torch um
runners and she has a tattoo on her arm
that says cause i'm free
i hope i hope she's wrong because that'd
be [ __ ] funny
well i just had to name kathy freeman
i'm hoping
along to everything else that's amazing
and what was really special that she got
in trouble for was that she took both
the australian flag and the aboriginal
flag and she softly intertwined it
together and she wore it after she won
and the olympics committee said that
that it wasn't allowed that it was
against the rules and i was like suck a
dick let her have her [ __ ] moment
yeah but that was really a moving time
for me when i was a very impressionable
teenager i was like kathy freeman wow
and i thought thank you for that sexy
dude
all right and this last thought she
couldn't do it final question just take
it kalila who's saying the opening
ceremony for the atlanta olympics
do you know wait whatever our options is
it whitney houston i know who it is you
do yes our options are
esther you know this pavarotti
michael jackson celine dion leanne
rhymes celine dion
okay
esther gets a tie for three and geo only
has one kalila has another three here we
go one let's uh
do do i get a hug now because i lost
you get to bend over and get spanked
there's a patient a point so everybody
gets a battle
yay
i love it here it's a new world guys
everyone gets a prize
can you can you can you hum a song while
you're putting it on
we have to um sing the national anthem
yeah
i've never got one of these
[Music]
that's a wig
yeah i'm just kidding
so you are not going to want to see what
i look like later
no you look like um like
you'd be an awesome
junior high friend of mine what
i had a sex doll i feel like a sex doll
you want this though well thank you geo
for being a wonderful guest and spending
all this time with us thank you thank
you for making me feel trashy and love
it super
good luck to you
in your first competition back next
weekend thank you um i'm very proud of
you thank you you're a really great
model for
us mid 30 somethings thank you
no truly
i'm not mid i'm definitely older 30s
annie and i are like have you seen geo's
post today don't say how how don't say
that all the time please don't have a
poster of you in my room no don't say
that
[Laughter]
thank you guys i love you guys thank you
guys we'll see you next week bye
you guys make sure you find geo um on
instagram i think her handle is geo
underscore antoinette geo underscore
antoinette but also she has a podcast
with her husband bart who we love and
that's called i can't pronounce it
correctly but i think it's called
bailcast like bear but in like a cute um
baby voice way it's kind of cute it's
like
b-e-a-w cast and that's their podcast
that they have
as a couple i've listened to it many
times so go listen
[Music]
you